muchas especies tienen ritmos
circadianos que presentan un ciclo de
aproximadamente 24 horas los ritmos
circadianos son controlados tanto por la
genética como por las condiciones
ambientales incluyendo la luz los
investigadores estudiaron el efecto de
la luz en el comportamiento de los
ratones mediante el uso de una rueda
giratoria con un sensor de movimiento
para registrar la actividad en acto
gramas como se muestra en la figura 1
muy bien así que vamos a pensar en lo
que la figura 1 nos está mostrando
tenemos una imagen de un ratón aquí que
parece estar inactivo definitivamente no
está en la rueda giratoria incluso tiene
los ojos cerrados tal vez está durmiendo
y aquí tenemos una imagen de un ratón
que está en la rueda giratoria parece
que está corriendo y tiene los ojos
abiertos y por acá vemos un acto grama
que tiene la descripción estrategia para
el registro de los datos de la actividad
del ratón cuando el ratón está activo en
la rueda giratoria la actividad
como una línea horizontal de color negro
en el acto grama cuando el ratón está
inactivo no se registra la línea
horizontal negra y podemos ver aquí que
nos da la actividad para cada día para
el día 1 el día 1 está justo aquí y se
puede ver que de la hora 0 a la hora 12
no está dibujada la línea negra el ratón
está inactivo no estamos detectando la
actividad en la rueda giratoria y luego
tenemos la línea negra de la hora 12 a
la hora 24 eso significa que estamos
detectando actividad en la rueda
giratoria por lo que podemos suponer que
el ratón está activo y por acá tenemos
lo mismo para el día 2 y por la forma de
este acto grama parece que el patrón se
mantiene igual para todos los días
avancemos un poco para la investigación
se utilizaron ratones machos adultos que
fueron alojados individualmente en
jaulas en un cuarto a prueba de sonido a
25 grados celsius por lo que querían
asegurarse de que los ratones no se
molestarán entre sí
definitivamente se encontraban en
condiciones controladas estaba en un
cuarto a prueba de sonido para que no
fueran afectados por ruidos externos
otros ratones o alguna variación en la
temperatura por lo que intentaron
controlar todas estas cosas cada ratón
fue dotado de alimentación adecuada agua
un espacio para dormir y una rueda
giratoria los ratones fueron expuestos a
periodos diarios de 12 horas de luz
denotado con una letra l mayúscula y 12
horas de oscuridad denotado con una
letra d mayúscula por su sigla en inglés
l 12 de 12 eso quiere decir que fueron
12 horas de luz y 12 horas de oscuridad
durante 14 días y su actividad fue
monitoreada de forma continua los datos
de la actividad se muestran en la figura
muy bien así que este es un acto grama
de la actividad del ratón bajo
condiciones l 12 de 12 cada fila
representa un periodo de 24 horas y las
líneas horizontales negras representan
la actividad en la rueda giratoria al
igual que en la figura 1 pero estos son
datos reales que fueron registrados así
que en las primeras 12 horas el ratón
está en condiciones donde hay luz y se
puede ver que en la mayor parte del día
uno no se detecta actividad en el día 2
tampoco se detecta actividad en el día 3
detectamos un poco de actividad pero en
su mayor parte durante las horas de luz
detectamos muy poca o ninguna actividad
y durante las horas de oscuridad ocurre
lo contrario detectamos una gran
cantidad de actividad en la rueda
giratoria hay algunos espacios por aquí
sin actividad pero en su mayor parte el
ratón está activo cuando está oscuro por
lo que el ratón está activo cuando está
oscuro
e inactivo cuando hay luz
qué es lo opuesto a lo que ocurre con
los seres humanos
nosotros tenemos una tendencia a estar
activos durante las horas de luz e
inactivos en la oscuridad
esto fue con 12 horas de luz y 12 horas
de oscuridad después de 14 días de el 12
de 12 los ratones fueron colocados en la
oscuridad continua denotado con dos
letras de mayúsculas de de su actividad
en la rueda giratoria fue registrada
como antes los datos de la actividad
bajo condiciones de oscuridad continuada
de se muestran en la figura 3 muy bien
esto es interesante en el día 1 los
ratones estuvieron inactivos esta vez no
por 12 horas como vimos cuando teníamos
12 horas de luz estuvieron inactivos
alrededor de 10 horas y a partir de la
hora 9 o 10 a aproximadamente la hora 21
estuvieron activos durante 12 horas tal
vez un poco menos de 12 horas y después
tenemos un periodo en que aparecen
inactivos activos inactivos activos así
que parece ser que durante menos de 12
horas estuvieron inactivos y luego están
activos durante menos de 12 horas y
vemos que esto cambia cada periodo de 24
horas ya que tienden a estar inactivos
durante menos de 12 horas parece que
durante 10 u 11 horas cada día y luego
están activos durante un poco menos de
12 horas y es por eso que vemos este
patrón cambiante donde cada día la
actividad inicia ligeramente más
temprano que el día anterior no es una
tendencia perfecta pero se ve la
tendencia durante varios días se puede
dibujar una línea como esta
y podemos ver que cada día se inicia la
actividad más temprano y cada día
también se termina la actividad más
temprano y hay mucha más actividad
esporádica se podría decir y recuerda
esto es bajo condiciones de oscuridad
continua muy bien vamos a ver si podemos
responder a las preguntas el sistema
nervioso juega un papel en la
coordinación del patrón de actividad
observado en los ratones en respuesta a
los estímulos de luz oscuridad describe
una función de cada una de las
siguientes estructuras anatómicas en
respuesta a los estímulos de luz
oscuridad un foto receptor en la retina
del ojo pues bien éste detecta la luz
detecta la luz y transmite
señal que
el tiempo
llega
cerebro muy bien el cerebro el cerebro
recibe las señales recibe las señales
y coordina la respuesta
de actividad
con base en las señales
así que esto es realmente solo responder
cómo funcionan un fotorreceptor un
cerebro y una neurona motora en relación
con esta prueba y una neurona motora
bueno estas son las neuronas que
estimularían se tiende a pensar en que
estimulan las funciones motrices y los
músculos pero también controlan cosas
como las glándulas así que
estimulan
y músculos
y cuando las y las glándulas podrían ser
especialmente relevantes aquí porque las
glándulas podrían ser las cosas que
liberan o no liberan las hormonas que
podrían poner a los ratones a dormir o
despertarlos
glándulas
podrían
liberar
hormonas relacionadas
con el sueño
vigilia muy bien creo que hemos hecho un
buen trabajo en describir el papel de
cada una de estas estructuras anatómicas
ahora vamos al inciso b con base en el
análisis de los datos en la figura 2
describe el patrón de actividad de los
ratones durante los periodos de luz y
oscuridad del ciclo l 12 de 12
bueno están inactivos durante las horas
de luz
estaban
inactivos durante las horas de luz y
activos durante las horas de oscuridad
las horas
oscuridad
esa es fundamentalmente la idea vivimos
por acá que en el siglo l 12 de 12
estaban inactivos durante las horas de
luz y estaban activos durante las horas
de oscuridad muy bien los investigadores
afirman que el ritmo circadiano
controlado genéticamente en los ratones
no sigue un ciclo de 24 horas describe
una diferencia entre el patrón de
actividad diario bajo condiciones l 12
de 12 figurados y bajo condiciones de
oscuridad continua las condiciones deben
la figura 3 utiliza los datos para
apoyar la afirmación de los
investigadores de acuerdo ya hemos
hablado de esto bajo condiciones de n
los ratones
están activos
e inactivos
por menos de 12 horas y entonces
podríamos decir
en comparación
con 12 horas
de inactividad
con l 12
y 12 horas
de actividad
con de 12 así que bajo condiciones de
oscuridad continua los ratones están
activos e inactivos por menos de 12
horas en comparación con 12 horas de
inactividad con l 12 y 12 horas de
actividad con de 12 así que es un ciclo
menor a 24 horas por lo que
es un ciclo
menor
a 24 horas
la actividad
es más
esporádica o podríamos decir que es
menos continua menos continua
definitivamente hay más veces en que los
periodos de actividad son interrumpidos
por los periodos de inactividad o los
periodos de inactividad son
interrumpidos por los periodos de
actividad muy bien dado que este vídeo
ya se alargó un poco voy a continuar con
los siguientes dos incisos en el
siguiente vídeo